kind of thing that was a guy character i
liked what was that show where the
character his whole thing is that he's
perfect
and he's a student um
he's so good so funny i did not go like
that was an anime that i heard was
decent and i was like i did not expect
to love that oh it's like
so funny if you haven't seen sakamoto
it's basically like the whole premise is
that
this guy is just the perfect human being
this is just the perfect sky
and everyone in the school is trying to
like [ __ ] with him and he somehow always
manages to flip it
like there was one time where they
needed to like make a fire in a room
yeah so he literally started doing like
back and forward right oh yeah he goes
back and forth
like jumping back and forth just start
off between the ground
starts a fire and it's like what i love
this i love this man i want to [ __ ] him
it's so good i loved him so much that
was like man
i wish i was that cool sakamoto like i
i'll be honest i didn't like it that
much
what is so funny
sakamoto pretty much like every problem
i have with most comedy anime
is in sakamoto which is i like the first
two episodes
and then i'm like i mean like oh is it a
joke
they're kind of doing the same joke over
and over and because funnier every time
for me i don't know
why because i knew it was coming it was
always funny when it came i don't know
why
it's like it's like you knew like
whatever situation it was it's like you
knew
he was gonna come out he's gonna solve
it but it's the excitement of like
how is that the absurdity of how he was
gonna overcome it i love that [ __ ]
because it completely defies
expectations of like oh he's probably
gonna do this but then they just
completely flip and be like yeah like i
didn't i there was no
point in my mind where i thought he was
going to friction burn
the floor into a fire to save all the
students like i didn't see that coming
and
then he was just like i just wanted to
work out yeah
and it's like what it's so fun that's
like
i love the comedy anime like that that
are just like not trying
too hard i guess yeah it's really weird
because i've had the hardest time
getting into comedy
comedy anime are normally the worst type
of there are very few comedy anime that
i enjoy
and i i put most of them in the same
category as like sakamoto where
it's it's funny to me for like one or
two episodes and then i get bored very
quickly if they're just kind of
doing the same thing i always need to
like i always need to be
like they always need to be doing
something different for me what about
what about something like nietzsche wait
wait yeah what's yeah nichijou and also
what do you think is like the best
comedy anime yeah oh that's awesome in
my opinion
yeah like off the top of my head
probably the
probably the hardest i've ever laughed
at a comedy anime was probably golden
boy
if you remember that oh yeah yeah yeah
um well that was mostly an old one
that's that's a really odd one and
that's the only like a six episode
overview so i i'd never got the chance
to get bored with it
and it is one of the best dubs i have
ever heard especially when it comes to a
comedy anime
because you must have seen the meme ever
like of of
the one clip where it's the guy doing
the swimming yeah
yeah that's the one clip that gets
shared out of golden boy and
if if you're gonna if you if you laughed
at that clip please watch golden boy
because
it's like ev every every point of golden
boy i feel like is just as good as that
clip
and that was that was just a one clip
that if if i would sell you on that show
yeah i could easily re-watch that
was also way funnier than i thought it
was going to be like
super good connoisseur i've i've really
enjoyed in the same way i enjoy like
uh always sunny in philadelphia or
something like that oh my god
it's it's just it's just a bunch of
awful people doing awful things like
this [ __ ]
it's an anime that's as awful as always
sunny always sunny is like my favorite
[ __ ] company
i love it so much yeah my god yeah the
corners of a movie as well was surprised
really funny yeah but it was also really
weird because it was really funny he had
no one in the cinema was laughing